monsieur eric mizera rang tandis que
l'hiver son vrai nom c'est hervé forneri
fondé et tu t'ai appelé dick rivers à
cause d'un film d'elvis exact qui
s'appelle loving you ouais alors j'ai
posé une question quand même une
différence et laquelle le prénom seddik
d'aircal bravo tu vois déjà très peu les
chats sauvages
ça vient du groupe du père une chanteuse
ou là
ah bon ouais tu sais toi c'est quoi les
wildcats marty wild et les wildcats le
père de jim white
bravo
en fait déjà les chats sauvages ça
durait qu'un seul était quoi ça a duré
deux ans où vient donc ça va durer vingt
ans mais ça a duré le premier disque on
l'a pris en avril 61 way et je les ai
quittés en outre 62 pourquoi on
s'entendait plus très très bavarde
aujourd'hui que la de coûts du rock and
roll faut bien dire quand tu pars et
c'est l'âge d'or de la pop d'âge d'or ça
s'appelle un âge d'or tout court ça va
être 183 je suis très content de le
faire parce que la musique ça m'éclate
et puis hamburger campagnard au kansas
et un bouquin était sorti à deux ans qui
à pied marche et là je prépare un roman
historique au rock'n relève d'un roman 1
qui sortira en même temps que le double
album que j'ai fini annonce à la
retraite qui sort fin en dominique phare
en toi tu es rtl j'ai pas depuis des
temps immémoriaux
ah ça fait quoi 17 ans non j'ai fait la
première prestation j'ai préféré rester
en 62 pour commenter les beatles apple
oeuvre mais je voulais mais je me suis
arrêté entre temps mais je dis la chose
vous avez envie de dire mme allende et
directeur adjoint des programmes
fin du service heart is weak plus vraie
saga la fête de la musique
ouais tu occupes la musique je lutte a
été journaliste fait toujours d'ailleurs
je suis oublie pas non je ne suis plus
vraiment je fais juste well as bossé
pour match aux usa sous ce pont
on va passer au jeu avec compositeur
alors à wendake stand by me kansas city
jay rock baby baby blog j'ai pas touché
même site
les brestois bravo
timo glock
reach out i'll be there la marque de 10
noms les compositeurs
duquenne trilogue tu connais pas non
berry gordy la mairie garder c'est le
patron de la maison des cent
non mais je doute les suprêmes tout
l'effort thot je connais que la bande 2
iron man u
j'aime le livre même quand ils seront 8
md on continue avec les compositeurs à
fait prêt oui date sur right mama elvis
54 ont repris par macarthur big boys
club wayne ivey chain repris par les
menus rock'n'roll et ma carte ne soit
pas qu'ils me laisser faire
ouais quand les projecteurs mais allez y
à du hall remember you can reduce berman
insan karnas my sweet lord suspects
bravo
continuer que les producteurs liées aux
normes l'amener à les yes we like
frankie goes to hollywood
video killed the radio star tu dois
connection wi sung eun morrison van
morrison a dit mme raveau un peu l'écart
vie bravo au caire comptant un peu plus
les chansons homonyme envoyé une chanson
qui s'appelle drive my car dans yes i
can leur avenir album de crosby david
crosby 89 et l'autre il ya baby you can
drive my car de witten sur quel album tu
sais le revolver na
un missionnaire sai mais il a dit lui et
si la nuit il fera beau sol comme ça dit
déjà j'étais sur un album des beatles
oui petit à petit alors toi tu connais
ou oman par bernard web et si tu connais
c'est un jour tu as dit à paul mccartney
quelle est la chanson que tu as écrit
deux cas pas eu de succès l'aja les
clips orbiteur en garde à un accord oui
c'est pas parce que vous m il ya une
chanson homonyme par qui le donne bravo
global champions alors on va faire les
one hit wonder
or si les mecs qu'on fait qu'un succès
dans leur vie à toi ma carte airport
bravo quel est le seul tube connu d
edwin hawkins singer 69ème bible ou non
vois-tu ses affidés ouais on fait